Quick question. Have you or anybody you
know ever said, "I'm tired of being a
beginner PO spinner." Sick of doing the
same three or four tricks over and over
again? Want to find a way to level up or
want to be able to get access to all
those cool tricks you see other people
online doing? Well, I'm here to help.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
give you five ways that you can finally
break out of the beginner's curse. But
before we dive in, I just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parot Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b businessiness friend
of the channel, Pekka Beckanin. Thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. So,
just to put this out there, everybody
learns at a different pace, and there's
no shame in being at a beginner level
for days, weeks, months, or even years
at a time. Sometimes the leaps come
quickly and sometimes they take a long
time to get to. Be kind to yourself and
give yourself some grace. Just because a
bunch of people that you knew jumped out
ahead of you, that doesn't mean that
there's something wrong with you or how
you're learning. There are plenty other
people out there that are in the exact
same boat that you are. But all that
said, if you are ready to push the
envelope and move on from where you're
at, I've got five different ways that
you can do it. Starting with tip number
one, make your practice regular. So,
this is definitely going to set a
precedent on this list that a lot of my
advice is going to turn out to be stuff
that either seems really obvious or that
is kind of boring. But here's the thing.
Sometimes those obvious and boring tips
are what work. If you're serious about
getting into intermediate po spinning,
you also need to get serious about your
practice. You need to make sure that
you're doing it regularly and that
you're really pushing yourself every
time you do it. Try and schedule
yourself 45 minutes to an hour of
practice every other day or if possible
every single day. You'll see results
almost right away. And it does need to
be said that we have neuroscience
research on the effectiveness of
practice and learning and progressing as
a result of it. And the thing is you
might be tempted to say on a weekend get
in four, five, maybe even eight hours of
practice and then have nothing going on
the rest of the week and it doesn't
work. What makes your practice allow you
to progress is to be doing it regularly,
which I know is a pain in the butt, but
hey, brain's got a brain, right? If you
can do an hour a day or an hour every
other day, you're going to be in great
shape.
Tip number two, gain repetition control.
So, this is a topic that I tend to harp
on a lot and that I harp on my students
a lot, too. Namely, when you get down a
trick, it's important to not just get
down the trick, but get down the control
of that trick. and being able to control
how many times in a row you do it. I can
and should be proud that I've gotten
down a three beat weave. But you know
what I should be aiming to do once I get
down that three beat weave? I should be
able to decide whether I'm going to do
it once,
twice,
three times and stop or whether I'm just
going to do it once and stop or whether
I'm going to do it a whole 10 or 100
times. Basically, you want to be fully
in command of when you start and also
when you stop the trick. Only then are
you in a place where you have enough
control over it that you can get into
intermediate territory with said trick.
And this will be true of every single
trick that you learn. So whether it's a
three beat weave, whether it's a thread
the needle, whether it is a windmill,
practice doing 1, 3, 5, all the way up
to 10 reps and then all the way back
down. When you have complete control
over that, you're going to be in great
shape. Tip number three, work on
restricted mobility plane control.
Goodness. So that's certainly a word
salad. What exactly does it mean? Well,
basically when we first learn most of
our PO tricks, we're learning them in a
place where our hands are in front of us
and we have the full use of our
shoulders, arms, wrists, and hands in
order to control the plane that the poi
are spinning in. But there are plenty of
cases where we have other spots where we
have a little bit less mobility that we
still have to learn our plane control
in. So, I'll give you three examples of
this in action. Starting with the first
poi trick that I ever learned in a
reduced mobility space, namely crossers,
which guess what? Your arms are crossed
in them. Now, this means that you're
working from a place where you have only
your wrists and hands to help you out in
controlling the plane of the po.
Granted, as you pivot your upper body
back and forth, it does have an
influence here, too. But in order to get
these down, as I showed in a tutorial
just a few weeks ago, you have to be
able to keep the PO spinning in plane
with your arms crossed as opposed to
keeping them in plane with your arms
uncrossed where you have all of that
lovely mobility to work with. Here you
have significantly more of a challenge
to keeping the poi in plane. Another
great example of this, which I hate
doing, is your behind the back PO
tricks. Once again, we're operating in a
place where our hands and wrists have
very, very limited mobility. And because
of that, we need to train ourselves how
to keep our planes straight in a spot
where we don't have a lot of control
over our arms to get there. For our
final example,
this right here, what is sometimes
called the no beat windmill. And really
what we're talking about is a place
where I'm keeping the poi behind my head
because my shoulder and upper uh arm are
really immobilized at this spot. I have
to once again not just keep control of
the plane with mostly my wrist and hand,
but I also have to do it in a spot that
I cannot see. So there's a funny thing
that happens when you drill these
things. That is when you practice
keeping your plane straight with your
arms crossed. When you practice keeping
your plane straight with your hand
behind your back or when it is behind
your head like so, it turns out getting
control of your planes in all these
different spots is going to make your
planes more clean overall. Even in the
spots where you can fully see everything
and you have full mobility of your hands
and wrists,
it has benefits beyond which you can
imagine. Tip number four, learn linear
isolations and extensions. So once
again, we are dealing with a bit of a
word salad here, but basically linear
isolations are these moments as we take
our hands back and forth when we have
the poi kind of poke out to either side.
Linear extensions are when we have our
hand move back and forth in a straight
line and the poi just spins around them
in a single beat like so. Now, these are
really important for several reasons.
When you get down your linear
extensions, you can use them to build up
tricks such as your triricetras or Xan's
diamond. Basically, anything made out of
straight lines, right? As opposed to
your linear isolations, which you can
use to get down your anti- spin flowers
or body tracers, as well as a host of
other tricks. But here's a little bit of
a secret. What linear isolations and
linear extensions are actually teaching
you is something that I like to call
beat control. That is, whenever we're
first learning our po tricks, we tend to
operate in this place where we keep our
hands more or less riveted in place and
we get into this regular kind of rhythm
where we do a beat every half a second
or so. And the thing is, when we start
getting into things like flowers, we
wind up in this weird kind of locked off
place where we keep having the poi spin
as we try and move our arms around. And
we need to be more in control of when
the PO spins and when it doesn't. Guess
what? Linear isolations and linear
extensions help you develop that
control. Once again, we're talking about
learning a very basic concept that is
going to have huge and wide-reaching
implications for your flow. Pick them up
sooner rather than later, and you'll
thank me later. Tip number five, drill
your transitions as often as you drill
your tricks. All right, so stop me if
you've seen this one before. You get
somebody who has just learned how to do
a three beat weave or maybe a butterfly
or maybe they're at a point where
they're still working on just their reel
turns. And every time they want to
switch into a different trick, they have
to completely stop their poi and then
get moving once again with the new
trick, which is really a pain in the
butt if you're doing this on fire. Am I
right? And here's why that happens. When
we are beginners, we get caught in what
I think of as being the trick trap. That
is, we're operating from a place where
we think of every trick as kind of being
an island of movement unto itself. And
we don't really work on getting back and
forth between those different islands.
And that needs to change. So, let's say
that you come up with a basic combo.
Start with like a three beat weave. You
do a pendulum to take yourself into a
thread the needle. And then you do
another pendulum to get you back into
that three beat weave. Guess what? You
need to drill the transition with at
least as much vigor as you do the
tricks. So rather than sitting here and
doing like 10 reps of the three beat
weave and then doing 10 reps of the
thread the needle, what I prefer you do
is first and foremost work on the
transition. Work on doing the thing
where you do the pendulum. Keep one PO
going and the other one switches
direction and once again pendulum. The
other PO keeps on spinning and that
takes you back into your tricks. Once
you get better at keeping one PO moving
while the other one switches direction,
I want you to drill these transitions. I
want you to think you're going to do
one,
two,
three, three beat weaves. Do the
pendulum. One, two, three. Thread the
needles. Back to your weaves. And you're
going to do three reps here. Yeah. The
thing is, you need to make drilling
those transitions at least as important
as the tricks themselves. And this can
actually manifest in a lot of different
ways. I have a drill I love to give my
students where I have them use pendulums
to get back and forth between all of the
wall plane timing and direction modes
that involve together time. Like so.
I also will sometimes have people just
go ahead and drill performing stalls
with one hand like so.
And then of course there's drilling
stalls with both hands and just seeing
how you do at getting around with the
different stall patterns you have
available to you. Again, make these as
important as drilling the tricks that we
all know and love. And what I can
promise you friends is if you take these
five tips from me, you will improve and
you probably will do so rapidly. So go
forth and see if you can get to those
higher levels. If you got anything out
of this video, please make sure to like,
share, comment, and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for your support. And if you out there
watching would like to get your name in
the credits or access to any of a host
of other awesome rewards, you can do
that by going and checking out my
Patreon at patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll include a link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. Thank you so much. Help me spread
the love of PO spinning and flow arts to
the whole wide world. And if you're
curious when you have arrived as an
intermediate PO spinner, what are the
things that you should be looking out
for in how you spin and what you spin, I
actually did a video a few years ago on
some diagnostics that I think will tell
you if you've arrived. I'll go ahead and
link to that on screen as well as down
in the description. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure to get up and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now.